on appelle une agence immobilière à
montreuil montreuil seine-saint-denis 93
ses primes et ses cadeaux oui je fais
des bisous à semnan way we passe moi
l'autre qu'on commet sa vue passe -
l'autre qu'on l'a bien l'autre con tu
dois savoir qu'il sait s'il n'est pas
très loin de poids passe le vide je
t'explique après merci beaucoup je te
fais confiance
le premier de plus con l'évidence va
vers l'évidence autour de moi il ya là
un il ya 22 ans
tu vois pas laisse parler son coeur va
vers lui
bah c'est l'appareil attend ensuite
monde ouais y'a quelqu'un qui veut te
parler non mais moi ils me voient parler
je sais pas quelle est tombé dans le
piège alors pas de toi toi même alors
c'est un gros con donc moi je dépends
des monstres et des bancs et qu'elle
nous en dit écoute ça dépend pour nous
dans la vraie vie ou pour ça on essaie
samedi voilà allez fin du bail alors
passez toile à bail doit gagner un
cadeau à gagner
ouais
mickaël delage de tête à montreuil c'est
cyril hanouna mon chéri ah bonjour oui
moi c'est pas très bon beaucoup plus
vite que toi et c'est laurent baffie est
avec moi abba bonjour bonjour gentil
alors tu travaille dans une agence de
voyage à lens immobile à merde alors la
lande ouest pour soi des billets je
t'offre un smartphone c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau oméga et beaucoup ça fait
plaisir mon chéri qu'est ce qu'ils
souhaiteraient en plus bavard avec bien
sûr alors là et c'est çà et là nous
sommes quand même c'est pas cyril
théréau faire mais qu'elle s'est c'est
oui
ah oui c'est trop bas c'est quoi une
voiture et 15 blessés walter black aces
tu veux on va dire bye et aux
smartphones et tu nous appellera tout
l'immeuble a laissé